ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
tornati su happy meal credibile ragazzi
di essere tornato sulla face perché tipo
lo faccio una domenica sì e quattro
domeniche no non si sa come mai tutti
ragazzi vogliamo iniziare lander the
movie allora mettetevi comodi la gara
ecco precisamente le sedie cavetti pop
con rega lander the movie agosto 7.995
vicino alla mia data di nascita
complotto a me è un film davvero c'è il
papa ma quand'è che tornerà mamma non ne
sono sicuro voglio cibo si paziente mi
abbia voglia avuto un incidente sono
all'ospedale prima di mezzanotte ragazzi
sta succedendo qualcosa di brutto ma
papà è proprio tutto a posto sale in
macchina a mano tempo di sbagliare come
cos'è successo giorno dopo a mezzanotte
ragazzi lo via l'ho visto l'ho visto
storie lei è morta la scorsa notte no
non è possibile avere veramente morta
ecco cosa cazzo abbiamo fatto continua
nel prossimo episodio i ragazzi chiunque
sia il regista melo portate qui davanti
lo bastona chiunque sia ninja massacro
mio dio cos'è sta roba che che belli
quello il tuo pene o era una tua spa nei
due perfetto nonno che cazzo fai di
precisa farlo per febbraio non senti ma
wingardium leviosa non lo so perché però
si staccano sono le tesse addio ragazzi
poi vj parrucchiere ci provare se
davanti come lo vuoi il taglio amico mio
perfetto questo credo che vada benissimo
duke come mai il taglio perfetto
spero vada bene mi ha dato una mano al
mio amico perché se no non ti
schiacciano cosi lasciamo perdere i
livelli
aspettavo questo momento da tutto vita
ghiaccio se io ti potrei non so dare un
po di spade per il compleanno
non so ti volevi diceva delle spade sei
contento adesso no allora ti diamo né
gli arpioni non sei ancora contento
allora stacchiamo ti le braccia ancora
non senso di sala nostra chiamati le
gambe però per concludere in bellezza
tanti amori york è perché oggi non lo
sapevate ma era il compleanno di yoox
quindi bisognava fare un compleanno
decente insomma c'è dentro uning dovrà
denunciare di mazzette pagate ragazzi un
bacetto arcobaleno mi serve devo che
possa seksich a luke non seriamente
[ __ ] a tuo fatto prima prenderemo
uno jacques stranamente non sono in più
l'ho preso ok ragazzi l'ultima ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] tu e le tue tette
minuscole
e non sono neanche bella devo non c'è
allora con la rossa siete sì ma che
cazzo ma dai non senti mai e non è che
posso andare avanti o troppo piano
o è troppo forte è finalmente mi tieni
non oggetto la data piano per perché ciò
paura di sbagliare pacquiao ma
[ __ ] tecnica [ __ ] no ragazzi non
farò mai un tutorial su come schivare
coltelli perché qua ci scappa il morto
sicuro save the world non salvare
l'hamburger cazzo o salato sava tutto il
tavolo la sedia tutto tranne l'hamburger
forse sono andato
noi non sono amante degli hamburger fino
a questo punto però ci riprovo all amico
mio dove chi con sosta roba
gli ho dato una botta della madonna la
faccia ce la faccio giuseppe ho fatto un
fuori campo di hamburger ragazzi ma
almeno è salvo almeno quello di haring
grande boxe you're in the box facciamo
questo
a caso a caso 5 fottuti secondi di
livello un record mondiale basta di dopo
questo non lo faccio più football game
cos'è sta roba oddio devo giocare contro
il computer ma sono contro una donna non
c'è verso ragazzi vincerò io ho fatto
effetto i fagioli che hai mangiato ieri
vedo ragazzi non si sa sta tirando tifo
squaraus o qualcosa del genere però sto
tirando testate a minchia ha così si gio
prefetto
no no ma come si fa a essere così
deficiente questi che pretendono di
prendermi per il culo perché ho perso
ok oggi non è giornata regala ok ok ok
guarda che [ __ ]
a parte che mi hai mandato la palla con
una velocità che forse se vado a
mangiare la mia nonna e toni non faccio
ancora in tempo a parare st palla perché
mi sa che non arriva in tempo noi noi
siamo qui hanno vinto non ho vinto un
cazzo perché non ti va a parare
questa tra queste palle non è possibile
non è forse lo ridà vasca che non sei
altro che alzi la gamba un po troppo
stavolta mi ha dato i cui occhi proprio
questo boltro pro mega morte cos'è sta
mega morte cielo ei o bieca ho beccato
giustamente quella santa claus la palla
la formula queen grazie babbo che
quest'anno mi hai donato un braccio
molto gentile dove si trova tantissimo
grazie proprio con questo non riesco
neanche più a prendere le palle
meraviglioso ragazzi per il regalo
giusto al momento già siro ci dispiace
si è rotto mi sono rotto anch'io però
adesso devo mandare sulla vittoria ce la
posso fare gara no no ma che cazzo no ma
avremmo così tutto il giorno finché non
becco la vittoria na sega proprio vinto
ho vinto occasione di palle ho vinto si
è posta di pudore che hanno va bene così
non facciamo di nuovo perché mio
denuncia farò mai più
l scalfisce amodio che non è brutto ma
che cazzo di figli a terra nova vengo
devo pescare no noi sono un peschereccio
in alaska sono gabbiani che dondolano io
non ho mai visto che avviene così ma non
importa ragazzi navighiamo come si deve
e non abbiamo a livello è fatto da dio
tanti ragazzi è uno sport che si fa in
alaska cioè si chiama proprio il lancio
delle poche vince chi la lancia più
lontano adesso sono in vantaggio io
perché l'ho lanciata io quindi è giusto
così non vi preoccupate delfino del film
non cazzo ragazzo catturare un definì
come si cattura come si pesca fermi che
devo catturare i delfini maledizione
come si fa festa e quello e l'altro
sport che fanno dall'altra parte
dell'anas che il lancio dei delfini
bellissima ma perché mi devono avanzare
grazie grazie amici miei a chi non è mai
capitato di una barca di sì capo tasse
perché degli stronzi lanciavano dei
delfini cioè succede spesso molto spesso
pdl cos'è sta roba che odio rai anche
bordello adesso giusto livello ax cosa
ho vinto ho vinto j ax è una cosa hanno
che cosa sta succedendo anno leale usher
frainteso camminati ma che ci posso fare
due palle 22 palle così perfetto di te
come faccio a prendere la vittoria no a
due palle di nuovo sì ok ok ho vinto ho
vinto basta l'altra
sono troppo pochi per ragazze ancora non
ho trovato una cosa che mi permetto fa
vj's trovo perfetto ragazzi ciao favi
questa seconda persone nel mio secondo
livello spero che ti piaccia e
finalmente potrebbe uscire anche
catemario fantastico ragazzi che hanno
fatto un livello che finito in topless
all altro per farvi j paj fa visse uscì
ticket mario vinci e dove cazzo sta a
steve kill him to look che ad uccidere
silvio per uccide per uccidere che mario
lurido prezzo di stronzo bisogna fare le
cose con ordine prima uk che c'è scritto
qualche devo ucciderlo ma allora siete
bastargli forte che ho fatto ci da
milazzo ma si può
l'ho preso subito ok cavi ragazzo questa
volta già fatta
stavolta ce l'ha fatta non voglio
rotture di palle boss verra un caffè
devo uccidere catemario quindi credo
calabra difficilissimo ho vinto
15 secondi credo sia un record sul mio
livello
ringrazio vynil vivi in abbina ville di
vini il 13 per il livello fantastico pur
andare loro e credo sia non lo sapesse
sono io perché mi chiamo lorenzo quindi
hanno abbreviato il nome o forse no e
burlando bollore a caso solo ragione
allora perché sono l'unico lorenzo
presente sul pianeta credo che questa è
mio è mio diritto mi sembra una roba
troppo strana come ecco infatti ho
massacrato qualcuno 321 questi ragazzi
che succede adesso è una cosa forse
quando vedo conti alla rovescia hanno
vinto mi sembrava mi sembrava mi
sembrava una cosa bruttissima ma ho
vinto ho un migliaio per cento in
passivo ragazzi facciamo con si vede
voglio darmi la dimostrazione che cazzo
sta succedendo rica fermi fermi il tuffo
sta merda di palla ma dove va buttata se
non ci fosse stata quella avrei
praticamente vinto volta ce la faccio
proprio volta ce la faccio
capito che deve fare il deficente
qualcuno ha qualche spiegazione per caso
no perché io non l'ho ufficialmente
capita questa ma va bene così house of
blood la casa del sangue cosa ovvia ecco
perché lei si chiama la casa adesso
c'era un motivo il capro in uno visto
amy ne va per un attimo si fa per noi
loro sì sì che curò regalo mi hanno
preso da cielo fatto che calmi calmi
calmi calmi slowdown spin inglesi io non
rallenta ma cosa me lo chiedere mia
madre wrecking ball perfetto no no no
non ce l'ho fatta per miracolo su questo
punto come
[Musica]
non so perché sto facendo così no
diminuisce la tensione si vabbè funziona
funziona e come come tattica funziona ho
provato che così ragazzi prima di
concludere volevo fare un altro livello
dei miei perché hanno già fatto una
prima vj versus non sa che cos'è sta
roba
sono uno sciacallo uccidi nomi ma sono
io non ho chukchi non sappiamo come dove
deve lanciare le bottiglie fare lì non
capitolo far ubriacare non lo sapeva io
li vado addosso [ __ ] e come al
solito finisco per accusarmi i piedi a
caso nei fenomeni possibile parma quello
che merda
sono vivo non sono vive più morto ma che
palle e impossibile fare soli no non
come fa uccidermi non è possibile
rilancio liocca sono finalmente suo
bambino di merda non serve comunque una
sega vabbè non ho capito dai nac jonica
non è possibile se mezz'ora per finire
sul livello mio dio papi j aiuto se fai
questo livello dovrò pulire tutta la
casa va bene allora vediamo che non sa
neanche partito a caso sono a metà a
caso cosa sto facendo
non sono nemmeno partito anche una
scritta che lui pensa che io riesca a
leggere ho vinto ho vinto monica super
fa vj ha fatto sto livello grazie mille
monica super fa vj con la prossima volta
dammi tempo di leggere la frase
all'inizio almeno perché non si poteva
manco respirare queste ragazzine che
posso concludere qui l'episodio con kakà
si servito è piaciuto poi solito
lasciato un commento mi piace anche
appoggiare facebook come noi lo trovate
nella descrizione se lo spettatore si
discreti amici belle ragazze